elon musk is not new to getting his best
employees poached by his competitors his
two successful companies spacex and
tesla produce excellent talent in their
respective industries companies looking
to compete are always offering lucrative
packages and faster career progression
tracks for people that are willing to
change companies just recently jeff
bezos hired rajiv beidau a former vice
president of satellites at spacex
suffice it to say this is a common
occurrence for elon musk today we will
be talking about one such executive that
used to work at tesla and who decided to
join an up-and-coming competitor this is
the story of peter rawlinson a former
executive at tesla who is now the chief
executive officer and the chief
technology officer at lucid motors this
is a story of betrayal and denial so put
on your seat belts peter wallinson like
elon musk is passionate about innovation
and pushing the boundaries whenever you
see him talking in interviews or videos
explaining the technology there is
always a shine behind his eyes it is no
wonder he and elon musk got along so
well peter rollins story starts in the
uk he was born in south wales he went to
imperial college london where he studied
engineering rawlinson would go on to
have a rich career in vehicle
engineering and the automotive industry
before he came across tesla rawlinson
served as the principal engineer at
jaguar he also led the engineering team
at lotus as a chief engineer rawlinson
was also the head of vehicle engineering
at chorus automotive simply put
rollinson had years of automotive
experience before he started testing the
waters for electric vehicles he joined
tesla motors in 2009 by then rollinson
was a veteran in designing and leading
automotive projects he knew a thing or
two when it came to cars compared to
elon musk who had up till then spent
most of his time developing software
platforms like paypal rawlinson had the
expertise to help steer tesla in the
right direction he served as the vice
president of engineering at tesla
rollinson also served as the chief
vehicle engineer for tesla's model s in
an interview rollinson recall when elon
came to him regarding the tesla model s
elon reached out to rollinson and told
him that the model s was in his words a
bloody disaster and he asked him to join
tesla motors to help them rollinson
joined tesla motors in 2009. after
joining tesla rollinson went to visit
elon musk at spacex to give his report
on the situation of model s rollinson
told elon musk that he would have to
start the project again from scratch
elon was a little taken back and asked
if anything could be saved from the
project rollinson assured him that if he
wanted the best car then elon had to
trust him and allow him to start the
whole model s project from the start
rollinson used his extensive experience
in the automotive industry to design
model s from scratch now that he wasn't
restricted by conventional drive trains
like those in internal combustion engine
cars he had more flexibility rollinson
was responsible for the technical
execution as well as the delivery of the
model s he was able to improve the
overall structure of the model s now
that he was not limited to an ice car
rawlinson was able to do all of this in
three years time and we all know that
the roadster might have put tesla on the
map but the tesla model s solidified
tesla as the market leader in the
electric vehicle industry rollinson was
a very important figure in making that
happen but this synergy between
rawlinson and tesla didn't last for long
as rollinson joined lucid motors as
chief technology officer in 2013. he
would rise in the ranks of lucid motors
to become the chief executive officer in
2019. he is currently overseeing the
development of lucid motors first
electric vehicle the lucid air so what
exactly is lucid motors well just like
tesla lucid motors formerly known as
ativa is an american electric vehicle
manufacturing company it is
headquartered in newark california the
company is a direct competitor of tesla
since both are purely electric vehicle
companies with similar routes like tesla
lucid motors also believes in vertical
integration as their own energy storage
and vertical equipment manufacturing
capability the company was founded in
2007 under the name ativa and initially
they were focused on building batteries
and powertrains for other electric
vehicle manufacturers the company
rebranded to lucid motors in october
2016 and officially announced that it
would be developing its own all-electric
high-performance luxury vehicle even
though it sounds like lucid motors is
directly competing with tesla rollinson
thinks otherwise he believes that lucid
motors is more of a luxury electric
vehicle brand and considers companies
like mercedes-benz to be their direct
competitors lucid motors wants to
initially focus on luxury cars and offer
electric alternatives to already
established luxury vehicles that wealthy
people use like mercedes rolls-royce and
bmw in december 2019 lucid started work
on their big factory in casa grande
arizona this would be their main
manufacturing facility for their
upcoming lucid air the construction of
the factory was completed by december
2020 and it cost lucid motors a vast 700
million dollars in investment the
company aims to produce 400 000 electric
cars per year what exactly is lucid air
it is the first electric vehicle being
developed by lucid motors it is the
brainchild of rollinson himself let us
go through some of the specs of the
lucid air lucid air is a four-door sedan
style electric vehicle that comes in
three variants one motor drive two motor
all-wheel drive and three motor
all-wheel drive versions lucid motors is
aiming for luxury and performance with
their first vehicle according to lucid
motors the air can do 0-60 in 2.5
seconds and do a quarter mile lap in 9.9
seconds these are supercar level
performance stats with their 3 motor
variant lucid air has a max power output
of 1080 horsepower this level of
performance will offer tesla serious
competition these numbers are comparable
to tesla's upcoming model s plaid the
model s will output 1020 horsepower the
model s plaid can reportedly do 0 to 60
in 2.07 seconds which is about half a
second faster than the lucid air if we
look at quarter mile lap time the model
s can do it in 9.34 seconds lucid air
and tesla model s plaid have eerily
similar performance and price points we
may see lucid air carve out a market
share for themselves with this kind of
performance the projected range of the
lucid air is about 500 miles on a single
charge this was verified by engineering
consulting firm fev north america this
is impressive by current standards to
put this into perspective tesla model s
long range offers 402 miles and lucid
air has a 28 higher range they plan to
offer 75 to 133 kilowatt hour batteries
with lucid air the most exciting thing
is their 900 volt plus electrical
architecture that aims to charge the
vehicle at a rate of 20 miles per minute
or 400 miles in 20 minutes the cheapest
variant of the lucid air is lucid air
pure and it starts at 69 900 and it goes
as high as 161 500 for the lucid air
dream edition to put the price into
perspective the tesla model as plaid is
expected to cost 131 thousand dollars
but the model s plaid is a high
performance version other model s
variants are significantly cheaper but
rawlinson expects that the price of
batteries is expected to drop to 100 per
kilowatt hour within the next decade and
this may pave the way for lucid motors
to make a luxury electric vehicle for
less than 30 thousand dollars lucid
motors has been able to achieve all of
this under the direction of rawlinson
but just as rollinson has been a
blessing to lucid motors he hasn't been
able to do this without ruffling some
feathers elon musk still seems to hold a
bit of a grudge against rollinson for
leaving tesla in 2012. even though that
was about nine years ago elon still
feels betrayed and hurt what is more
painful for elon musk is that peter
rollinson went to work and consequently
lead lucid motors direct competitors for
tesla and losing your top talent to the
competitor isn't a great feeling in fact
elon musk's feelings for wallinson hit
the news when in reply to another tweet
elon denied that rollinson was ever the
chief engineer on the model s project
elon was clear that rollinson came
before the model s project started and
then left when things got tough but the
problem is that this doesn't seem to be
the case a blog post on tesla's website
from 2010 clearly refers to rollins in
joining tesla as the vice president and
chief vehicle engineer and it's not just
limited to that on tesla's official
youtube channel there are videos of
rollinson showing a model s under
construction in the video rollinson is
showing a model s on the car that is
being produced it is a bare bone
structure of the model s that rollinson
goes around and explains he talks about
things like a new advanced crumple zone
in front of the model s in subsequent
videos he talks about the sensors on the
model s and its braking system in these
videos rollinson is introduced as the
vice president of engineering it may be
that elon musk may just have
misremembered rollinson's position but
it is more probable that elon is a
little hurt and salty that rollinson
left and now he wants to revise
rawlinson's contributions to tesla it
should come as no surprise that as we
move toward a more sustainable future we
see greater competition between both
upcoming and established electric
vehicle manufacturers healthy
competition between companies is always
good for the customer and with rollinson
leading a direct competitor against
tesla this may brew a constructive
rivalry between the two companies this
way both companies will be pushing each
other to create the best electric
vehicle competition nurtures innovation
only time will tell if lucid motors is
up to the challenge and if rollinson
made the right decision to change shop